we're listening into the interview with
the health secretary what did you make
of what you had to say so in terms of
the advice of the public we would
absolutely support everything he said in
terms of encouraging everyone to stay at
home especially given the really good
weather than we're experiencing so
please do stay at home helpless in the
NHS and protects us by staying at home
and not exacerbating the spread of the
virus and that's the safest way of us
getting through this crisis but we are
concerned and I think hearing from the
health secretary that he's trying to
support an HHS staff at a time when
we're hearing we still have issues with
personal protective equipment with
testing and frontline staff and that's
still a concern that's ongoing and I
don't think he's really addressed some
of those concerns for my nature staff
and his comments today
can you just spell out what it is like
on the front line you've been surveying
some of your members I think what is it
you found so yeah unfortunately it's
been two weeks since the health
secretary said that he's pledging to
ensure that the right equipment gets to
the right doctor of the right Hospital
and the right GP practice and we've seen
that sadly that's that's still not
happening so doctors have been left with
no choice but to take matters into their
own hands at the doctors Association UK
we've been working with Nestle and we
create an app for the NHS PPE comm and
so since Thursday we've been surveying
hundreds of doctors in over 150
hospitals and they've told us 43% of
doctors have said they've got absolutely
no eye protection at all with nearly 20%
telling us and they have no eye
protection for the most severe and most
high-risk aerosol generating procedures
doctors have said that they're having to
reuse masks and it should be single-use
only and sometimes they're talking to
nurses and nurses are doing some of
these high-risk teachers and trying to
hold their breath because they're unsure
and unaware of whether the mass they've
been provided is gonna offer them
adequate protection this is really
harrowing to hear so many stories across
the NHS and it's pretty staggering to
hear
that to be honest over 40 percents and
they didn't have eye protection people
having to hold their breath because
they're worried the government says it's
really trying to address the issue of
protective equipment that it's the
supply that has been lacking is the
situation improving so we have seen in
certain centers that the supplies are
getting to the front line and we're
hearing everyday of more and more cases
and particularly with general
practitioners who simply just don't have
the eye protection and basic equipment
that they need now some places are
getting a delivery and then may not get
a further delivery for several weeks and
so they deplete they stop well in
advance of the neck delivery and we've
seen doctors resorting to accepting
donations from local schools for example
of using science goggles that children
would normally be using in their labs
but repurposing those be used in their
surgeries and so we've seen tremendous
amounts of effort from the local
community to try and get personal
protective equipment to doctors and in
the absence of things coming from from
the department house well we've seen
some really sad cases this week of
nurses losing their lives after testing
positive for Kovac 19 in Italy more than
50 medical workers have succumbed to the
virus how concerned are you about the
safety of people working on the front
line absolutely say alongside the safety
of our patients the safety of our
workforce our doctors and nurses on the
front line is our paramount concern and
given that the severe lack of personal
protective equipment is getting 3 and
we're all very concerned about
potentially losing more colleagues it's
sad to hear that we've already lost
doctors and nurses in the line of duty
and doing their very very best for
patients and none of us wants to hear
where the stories of frontline staff
losing their lives not Hancock was
saying that they are keen to try and run
part testing particularly of course of
NHS workers as well trying to hit the
target of a hundred thousand a day is
that news that you welcome
absolutely we've heard the last few
weeks that testings going to be ramped
up so it would be welcome used to see
see that actually happening in practice
he spoke about 10,000 tests a day and
some of those already for NHS staff but
those have not come without problems as
well so we've heard from doctors who
have been sent to a testing center only
to be turned away and told that their
name doesn't appear on a list and these
are individuals who are isolating they
may not currently have symptoms but they
may have family members for example in
the household that have symptoms and so
hearing that almost 15 percent of
doctors three times the number that the
heart secretary quotes are currently off
work is a significant amount of the NHS
workforce an answer worried going
forwards that we can't get these people
tested quick enough and get them back to
work
yeah clearly a bit of a dispute about
the number of the proportion of doctors
and other staff of work self isolating
and and just finally you can see that
the government's been trying to ramp up
the capacity in the NHS building new
hospitals trying to get more ventilators
for example but those numbers of cases
the number of people going to hospital
keeps ticking up across the country
what's the situation like in the NHS at
the minute is the health service coping
so health services is very resilient
we've had pressures and we know that
over the last few years we've talked
about winter pressures being almost all
year round so we've we've gone into this
pandemic in a position of relative
weakness however every single member of
the NHS is on hand to give 110 percent
and to do everything they can to ensure
that we pull through this and I'm sure
that my colleagues around the country
are doing absolutely everything they can
in terms of ventilators and vents most
hospitals have got a surgeon and expands
in places of how they're going to
accommodate more patients and we've seen
the opening of the nightingale hospital
and plans for further
similar Nightingale hospitals that will
help with the pressure so we're hopeful
that these measures that are put in
place are going to be sufficient but
obviously these things are being
reviewed on a daily base
as the situation evolves